welcome to new gaming Network this is
just another quick build
run-through video as always if you
require more details let me know in the
comments below today we're talking PvE
and how in my experience for the dozens
of builds I've been trying out that this
is the best easiest build for taking on
the PvE content and the division I'm not
claiming this is the fastest build for
clearing content and when it comes to PC
players there are a few other options
out there but when you're on console and
your aims as averages mine this build
will help clear even the most difficult
tve content in the game
I've used this challenging mission
underground light zone farming
incursions and even soloing the new
legendary missions which you can see on
one of my other videos they wander this
build feels pretty damn cheesy as of
right now and 1.6 PvE with the way that
skill power stacks up burnished this is
the way to go sure you're a little
squishy and your dps is a little low but
it's okay your skills are doing most of
the damage for you anyway when it comes
to the most difficult PvE content the
difference between 500k toughness and
300k toughness is a fraction of a second
to another heavy NPC fire why not deploy
something to be doing flesh taking the
damage for you while you sit safely at a
distance this isn't to say you won't be
firing you gun at all in fact I'll be
showing your weapons that always
consider completely pointless on console
until now when I first threw this bill
together it was intended mainly for solo
play as I spend a lot of my time in the
game on my own however as I tweaks the
build I realized its usefulness in group
play - now there's a lot of room for
personalization in this field what works
well for me might not be the best for
your style of play so change things up
see what you came up with
this bill consists of three pieces of
tactician and three pieces of fire
creased by Chris Pharisee method Buster
flame tone and technicians for its
busted skill power and skill taste all
pieces of inderal through skill power
and all major attributes to skill power
first or health of skill calories and
available all mods or electronics with
yep you guessed it more skill power as
the attribute the primary weapon I'm
using with this build is the urban MDR
this weapon synergizes so well with this
build because India's unique talent your
damage is increased by 18 percent
against targets with status effects the
fact that everything you do with this
build either causes bleed or fire status
effects you actually end up getting a
decent amount of damage out of is with
them even with nothing put into firearms
my secondary weapon is more for healing
purposes with predatory and the free
talent slot all I need to do is be
holding this weapon one of the skills of
killing things for the talent to be
propped to pull it out heal up jump back
to the MDR if you hadn't guessed it by
now the skills equipped our flame
turrets and cluster secant lines talents
include critical says because generally
if you need it use a med kit with the
spills you're in trouble for the extra
of damage resistance might provide you
enough time to give back to safety tech
support to keep your current active for
longer wildfire to have your turrets
spread the damage to more targets and
chain reactions to have your seeker
mines do more damage I'll leave this
going with a little bit of gameplay now
thanks for watching this video please
leave any feedback below and if you'd
like to see more division content from
me Chuck us a like and subscribe Cheers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you